yeah welcome to this video playing sue
Shanghai again I'm just just played in
before with black this rarely happens
that you have those back-to-back games
and let's see what happens the night off
I really don't know those sharp lines
okay come on let's play something there
should be three I didn't place didn't
play at all or not much it is a sharp
line of course okay yeah put f3 is the
English attack do you first play G for
Queenie to don't know g5 before this is
a real real legitimate line young hmm 95
is so this bad
maybe I can killer can i play like this
just 95 not playing d5 so quickly
yeah well I have no idea what I'm doing
here 28 for 27 this haven't looked much
more I don't know natural or
conventional to me but okay I really
don't know this opening maybe may be
here if it takes young knight to e5
Knight e5 to c6 looks looks nice yeah
just doesn't really react to all of this
hmm Bishop to d3 is this good hmm now
almost like f-4s can maybe be sure
before
yeah anyway we should be for Bishop g2
yeah the knight on c6 is really I
thought an annoying piece but maybe it
is not so so bad
yeah it's not easy to to make any
progress it looks nice but how do you
actually prove it
I didn't want to exchange the rocks so
much but Luke c1 also looks like a less
than attractive muth I'm not so sure
maybe an endgame is not not a bad thing
what why not just exchange it yeah okay
don't know quite we had to give me the
phone but
and as I mentioned it's not easy to get
ahead here
yeah okeee time in a self-penned now
queen at five probably yeah this wasn't
your take
and this would be six is not not on this
was bad yeah Bishop before this was
really an amazingly bad plan I mean
trying to utilize this rupee eight idea
Bishop takes rook e8 winning the Queen
but there's probably some sort of
drawback to this rook rook here i can
play wii piayed yeah i don't see the
refutation at the moment I'm pretty sure
this one it looks like why does just and
now you gave it made and the queen is
saying what what are you doing now it is
also it doesn't have a check funny
enough
black resigns huh Karen I'm surprised
but it seems winning him yeah it is
winning just switched on the comp + 5
appetit discern this must be a problem
here i mean this i played this really
like a complete complete [ __ ] it should
be fun be sure before was really great I
thought Bishop before Queen d3 maybe
something but of course he just wants to
exchange yeah Bishop f3 okay that Bishop
f3 is the computer move just I'm doing
nothing but this leads to a ridiculous
Self pin it can also play 95 now is also
good and here the computer actually
gives night before s ok i am ok but here
he just to take with the Queen em and
just just an advantage for black yeah
black is a pawn up it's not entirely not
completely easy but you should you
should probably win it now it takes a
now I have this trick but twenty seven
seems to seems to be okay and this is
winning now we cannot it takes itself
it's a simple mate he doesn't have a
check this is Sir of course one thing I
di just just take it so Queen put two
pieces and I've there's still this back
Reggie sure so you will probably lose
more material strange game yeah thanks
for watching I didn't understand
anything maybe you understood moved